you're an absolute lunatic who is
obviously just facilitating the larger
transfer of wealth of your money to of
course the big Banks the big
corporations that truly do call the
shots at government and the most
powerful people are only enriched by
more government look that's racist I
don't give a damn what it is it's the
truth and I'm speaking my truths here
because because can you see it well make
a counter argument
how long until they uh write an article
saying Republicans effort to abolish the
IRS is rooted in white supremacy I
guarantee it exists it'll be soon a
hundred percent it exists because they
probably wrote it about Libertarians
already it probably already yeah it's
probably already there you just gave him
a great headline idea so next week I
would say Media Matters get on it you
write that thing I'm a person of color
so so they can't make that argument
personally I'm trans-racial you can be
transgender actually so I think I found
I think about the opposite how federal
tax law hurts black Americans thank you
which is probably yeah so actually the
IRS is racist yes the tax codes racial
disparities well we got to get rid of
all that